why we got more time behind us than in
front please I'm gonna be running down
criminals til I'm a hunter it was great
to see you and Marcus back together
fighting crime Ike bad boys for life was
everything we wanted it to be and more
but life has thrown you some curveballs
hasn't it we were shocked when we found
out the big secret in the new movie who
wants to kill you I don't trust a person
that don't want to kill him we were all
so glad that the ending was left wide
open we can't wait to see what happens
in bad boys for bad boys for life was a
fun return to the lives of Marcus
Burnett and Mike Lowrey you could get
that buffed out no you can get that buck
down we never want to guess the ending
find out what the ending means for a
future bad boy sequel this video
contains spoilers you've been warned
bad boys for life was a wild ride and we
would expect nothing less from this
franchise when the movie opened we were
sad to learn that Mike Lowrey and Marcus
Burnett weren't working together anymore
Marcus has been a family man for a long
time now and he's just become a
grandfather
he's kicking a desk job at some point
since the last film and he's perfectly
content to be out of harm's way
he's even thinking about retiring
meanwhile Mike is still fighting crime
in the police force but he keeps butting
heads with the younger cops in ammo the
advanced Miami Metro operations unit
Mike survives an assassination attempt
at a party he was attacked by Armando
who had recently helped his mother
Isabelle escape prison they have big
plans for their cartel and Armando is
supposed to take out everyone that gets
in their way Mike makes a full recovery
but Marcus still doesn't want to go back
into the field this causes a rift
between the two lifelong friends things
take a turn for the worse after that we
lost one of our favorite characters
Armando goes after captain Howard and
the sniper attack was successful rest in
peace captain Howard this is what
finally makes Marcus decide to return to
fighting crime with Mike they take on
Isabel in armando's cartel with the help
of the awesome new cast everything is
way more complicated because mo hasn't
been very successful lately it's in
danger of being shut down and just when
you thought there weren't any more
issues Mike throws Marcus and everyone
in the audience another curveball
Armando is his bi
illogical son our jaws hit the ground
when he announced this basically many
years before Mike had gone undercover to
infiltrate the cartel he had an affair
with Isabel and she got pregnant it must
be terrible for Mike knowing that his
own son has grown up to be an assassin
in the end there's a major fight scene
Mike reasons with Armando Isabel tries
to shoot Mike but wounds her own son
instead Rena who becomes the new captain
takes out isabel armando survives and
goes to prison later we see mike asking
him for help in exchange for a sentence
reduction and most importantly marcos
decides to go back to fighting cartels
with mike if bad boys for life was the
end of the sequel things would have been
different either Mike or Marcus would
have ended up retiring at the end of the
movie they would decide that they were
just too old for the hectic cop life and
we don't think that they would have
introduced Armando as Mike's son if they
didn't have big plans for him later plus
the new cast of cops of stolen fans
hearts they invested a lot in several
new characters keep watching to find out
what all this means for bad boys for all
right now it's time to be good men
before we dive into the theories about a
fourth movie let's talk about what the
movie has to include first up we
definitely need more information about
Armando honestly we kind of feel bad for
him he grew up in a cartel and was
trained to be an assassin he never had a
chance at a normal crime free life also
he just found out the truth about his
father that his mother passed away after
accidentally harming him he's got a lot
to deal with while he serves his prison
sentence we also really want to see
Gabrielle Union again she played Sid
Marcus's sister who was an undercover
DEA agent the fourth movie also needs
some sort of reference or homage to
captain Howard Joe Pantoliano has been
such an awesome part of the bad boys
franchise we understand why his
character had to get shot in the movie
Marcus needed a reason to go back into
the field but will miss him
be sure to at least be mentioned a few
times in a fourth movie we also really
want the same directors to come back for
a fourth film the first two movies were
directed by Hollywood legend Michael Bay
but a deal LRV and bilal fala took the
helm for the third movie and their
version was a breath of fresh air
we want to see what else these directors
can do with all the characters that we
know and love and of course we
definitely will need Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence to reprise their roles
sometimes major action franchises try to
spin off sequels with new main
characters but we just don't think that
will fly with bad boys fans I got this
I'm gonna penetrate this man's soul in
my heart what when they left the ending
of bad boys for life open they wanted a
chance to return for another movie if
the third flick did well at the box
office so far it's doing great the
studio is already talking about a fourth
installment and there are plenty of
directions that the storyline could go
the first theory is totally obvious and
it has to do with Armando obviously Mike
is a good guy and he loves the Sun he
really wants to have a chance to have a
relationship with them we bet that Mike
starts visiting Armando in prison a lot
and we definitely want to see this
father-son bonding happen Mike has never
been one to be tied down he's never been
married and he's had different love
interests in every movie but now he has
a family Marcus on the other hand has
been a family man for a long time we'd
love to see him help Mike navigate being
a father and the plot is already there
Mike asked Armando to help with a case
our mando has a lot of knowledge about
cartels he'd be a valuable asset to any
case maybe Mike manages to get him out
of prison early to assist Armando could
help Mike go undercover to take down a
cartel plus there's a chance for some
intrigue the audience will always wonder
if Armando can really be trusted it
could even cause a rift between Mike and
Marcus we think this theory is very
plausible and we would be really
disappointed if the next sequel doesn't
include Armando wolves is that Sid
another option is for a crossover with
LA's finest remember Sid in bad boys -
we met Marcus's sister Sid she was
secretly dating Mike and now they were
worried about how Marcus would react he
didn't really take it great at first and
sit in Mike didn't stay together Sid was
such a beloved character that she got
her own spin-off show Gabrielle Union
brings Sid to life in LA's finest she
has left the DEA and is now working with
the Los Angeles Police Department her
partner is Detective lieutenant Nancy
McKenna who was played by Jessica Alba
Nancy is married to the district
attorney who has a daughter Ellie's
finest started in 2019 and the second
season comes out sometime this year I
got to deal with this face first thing I
did was wife up we would absolutely love
to see the show bras over with bad boys
for it would be a double buddy-cop movie
with Sid and Nancy as the other best
friends a cartel investigation could
easily bring the detectives together
cartels usually have influence in more
than one city or maybe Mike and Marcus
are asked to consult with the Los
Angeles Police that could be the case
that Mike asks Armando to help with he
could be doing it as a favor to Sid
there's also the possibility of a love
story for Mike in bad boys for life we
find out that Rita is his ex-girlfriend
that would definitely complicate their
working relationship since she's the new
captain he could absolutely get back
together with Rita in the fourth movie
Rita was played by Paola Nunez and she
was such an awesome character of course
Mike still might have feelings for Sid
if there was a crossover that broad said
back those two could rekindle their
earlier romance Marcus would probably
approve these days since everyone is
older and more mature but that could
mean the end of Ally's finest if Sid
moved to Miami to be with Mike Mike
could also moved to LA to be with her
though or there could be a brand new
love interest for him either way we hope
we get to see more Rita in the fourth
movie she and the other new characters
were so much fun
you might be wondering why bad boys for
life didn't get made until 17 years
after the second movie and it's easy to
worry that the same thing will happen to
the fourth film but there are several
factors that led to such a huge time lag
between the two sequels one of the major
issues was the budget bad voice too had
a huge budget and it wasn't nearly as
big of a success as the producers had
hope but the new directors managed to
make bad boys for life on a limited
budget they hired the best in the
business and decided to focus on
practical stunts / CGI they also kept
the action shots shorter and it didn't
detract from the movie at all
they also struggled to find the right
story they wanted to tell a story that
old fans and new fans would be happy
with many ideas were suggested and
thrown out over the last 17 years Kris
Bremner worked with joe carnahan and
Peter Craig on the story for bad boys
for life Joe and Peter helped craft of
the story but most of the screenplay
credit goes to Chris Chris has been
tapped to write the next bad boys movie
as well Sony isn't talks to make the
fourth movie happen but it's still in
the early stages we hope that the
success of bad boys for life makes them
decide to go through with it the studio
does not want there to be the same time
lag between movies so we know it won't
be too long what do you think will
happen in bad boys 4 tell us your
theories in the comments section no
never
y'all will never do that again that's a
wrap
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the things for more thanks
for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you